hello everyone and welcome to Game nine
of the 1972 World Chess Championship
match between Boris kusenov it Spassky
and the Robert James veteran now if you
mean with us so far you know that the
result is currently five to three in
Fischer's favor and it's not like five
to three is unreachable for Spassky the
problem is is possibly won the first two
games he won the first game with Fischer
blundering that Bishop and six second
game was a forfeited by official without
playing a single move so out of the next
six games
Spassky only got two draws and Fisher
has won four games so that's you know
psychologically that's a pretty big big
hit to take and possibly require a
request at a time out each of the
players has the option of postponing the
match three times
so as passkey is not requesting one
although he didn't want to he didn't
want it to seem like he'll like the one
bent Larsen used when he said he was
suffering from altitude sickness you
know high blood pressure or like Tigran
Petrosian asked for timeout due to some
nervous nervousness and anxiety anxiety
so Spassky had an official note issued
from his doctor but the American chess
federation requested to see the snow and
this is something that's the quote about
the board says how about that it was a
title in the newspapers not the
newspapers in the American radio station
however they said you know what is this
now Spassky is now losing it now he's
requesting a timeout because something
definitely has to be done here and there
were rumors that Geller was a recall to
the Moscow he had to explain the current
situation in the match and so on and so
on so there there was a still drama to
this match during game eight there were
cameras rolling in the room in the plane
call but Fischer didn't know about them
so Fischer only found out that the
cameras were recording after the night
after game eight and then he again was
very angry and then he was again
threatening to leave the match even
though by this point he's now winning
five to three no one was actually
considering that he would actually leave
but you know
there's a this struggle will the cameras
be on where will the cameras be will
they be there without Fisher noticing
them like there were in game 8 so they
really have to Chester Fox really had to
figure this out if you wanted to get his
money's worth also a really good which
mentions in his book Jerry Weintraub the
former promoters or a promoter of Elvis
Presley was in town and also Sid
Bernstein a one-time manager of beetles
and mr. Jerry Weintraub promoter of
Elvis Presley said that even though he
had no idea who Fischer was like a week
ago now it seems like Fischer is like
this superstar and everyone in the world
knows about him which in fact was the
case and he said that he's never seen
anyone rise from let's say nobody to to
hunt to a superstar this fast you know
and he was the promoter of Elvis Presley
so that was that's very interesting
so yeah they did say that Fisher Fisher
will be the first real American
millionaire that that comes from chess
which was unthinkable you know a lot of
chess players a lot of chess champions
spent their entire lives in poverty so
this was definitely something new to the
to the whole game but ok that being said
let's return to the game as possibly has
the white pieces and he opens with d4 so
returning to his original pre-match idea
Knight to f6
we have c4 and E six Fischer again goes
for this timid line preparing the Queens
gambit declined and he doesn't go for g6
the Kings Indian defense because he
simply doesn't have to just yet
it's okay c4 e6 we have Knight to f3 and
now d5 if it was a like a really
important game that Fischer had to win
most likely he would have gone for c5
the man only defends but here Fischer
transposes into the Queens gambit
declined we have nice to see three and
now comes bishop sorry c5 Bishop to b4
was played in game number one and we all
know how that turned out here see if I
was played and again as Spassky is
really an
expert with both black and white pieces
in this line Fisher is here again
challenging Spassky to his knowledge of
theory seek capture son d5 we have ninth
capture son d5 and now II four here
Fischer allows this very sharp line with
E for as poss he defeated Tigran
Petrosian in 1969 their World Chess
Championship match in this line so
Fischer definitely has something up his
sleeve we'll just have to see what it is
Knight captures on c3 we have big
captures on c3 and now see captures on
d4 see captors on d4 and now comes
Knight to c6 the most popular line was
Bishop to b4 check here but black didn't
really get to any good results here so
instead the Fischer goes nice to see six
and it's very interesting
again Fischer goes for a line that was
played with the black pieces by Spassky
second Nikolai Kroger's Curly's had this
position against platinum in Leningrad
in 1971 so again it seems like Fisheries
testing Spassky are you carefully
listening to to what crow goose is
suggesting before the game that's ok
Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 other
reactive square for spots this Bishop
that will at some point allow Spassky to
execute to this central thrust with d5
and this is move 10 sorry this is move 9
and here and move 9 Fischer unleashes
yet another novelty here fish replace B
5 B 5 is well of course you're not gonna
capture it if you capture it Queen to a5
wins the bishop it's not not a very deep
idea but what Fischer plans to do with
this b5 move who wants to at least get
this Bishop to a to a less less active
square for example d3 or e2 and then he
will be able to start to developing his
Queen side if you go Bishop back to b3
then Bishop to be before check is coming
and black will definitely get a lot of
activity so Spassky goes to Bishop to d3
Bishop to e2 is also a possibility but
here it's you can't win a pawn or
something if you capture here then
Knight captures on d4 and now you cannot
capture because
Bishop CalPERS on b5 wins the Queen but
Bishop to b4 check first
it doesn't help you because King to e2
is coming and again you cannot capture
because of the same idea you would lose
your queen
so after Bishop to d3 up to d3 we have
Bishop to b4 check by Fischer butter up
to d2 blocking and now Bishop captures
Queen captures on d2 and now comes a six
here our Fischer defends his b5 pawn
he's ready to play Bishop to b7 and it
seems like all is well for black black
managed to nicely develop and he will
not have any problems developing his
light-square bishop which is most often
the case at the biggest problem when you
play the Queen's Queens gambit decline
is the what to do with your light-square
bishop
so here Spassky immediately tries to
break this Queen side pawn chain with a
for attacking b5 but also a very very
interesting idea was d5 and now after a
captures he captures you have to figure
out what to do capturing the fourth the
pawn would seems would give white a lot
of activity after castles and now we
have to figure out how to go about this
go about this the hunt the rooks are
coming into the game and it would be it
would be pretty dangerous
you cannot castle just yet because
Bishop captures on h7 wood we need the
Queen so the black would black would
have some problems here but after it
captures on d5 you could go for
something like Knight to a5 and now
after Queen to III check Queen c7 and
now Castle you would still prevent black
from castle ink and black would have to
figure out what to play here so this
would definitely be an okay idea for
white of course if you capture the Queen
then F captures on e3 and now White has
a very nice central pawn structure our
butter case basically has a different
idea instead of this central thrust he
goes for a four we have castles by
Fischer a very nice move as now pawn
captures and b5 will be met with Knight
chapters on d4 now this is definitely
possible since the King is safely tucked
away here on g8 now after a queen e3
attacking the knight Knight captures
Queen captures on f3 and now simply rook
to b8 and now if Bishop captures on a6
Fischer wouldn't mind
giving up this pawn even allowing such a
very strong passport because now rook to
b3 will start a very nice attack for
black if a seven rook Bishop to b7 is
coming with a nice double attack against
this d3 Bishop and a very nice monster
Bishop on b7 this would definitely be
compensation enough for the past a 7th
pawn so you don't really want to allow
such an attack to Fischer for the price
of one pawn so after castles we have
Queen to c3 by Spassky moving the Queen
out of the way with an attack against
officials knight on c6 Bishop to b7 a
nice development move also defending the
knight on c6 and now comes a capture Sun
b-58 capture some b5 and now castles
legal it mentions in his book that
perhaps capturing the rook would have
been better here but the engine actually
likes Fischer's idea as well
so simply castles here's Spassky castles
and Queen to b6 we have rook a to be one
now piling up on that b5 form and now
simply be for attacking the Queen Queen
moves the d2 and now Fischer captures on
d4 Knight chapters on d4 it seems like a
better idea of perhaps to keep the
attention and proceed with pushing the
pass point to be three but it would be
all the same if b3 then Queen to be two
you can pile up against the b3 pawn
Knight a5 defending and now comes Knight
to d2 adding another attacker to the
story to the b3 pawn and after rook F to
d8 now attacking the d4 pawn here you
can simply capture it Knight captures
and now Queen captures on B 3 but now
Queen captures on d4 with the idea that
if Queen capture some b7 then Queen
captures on d3 and after rugby to d1 you
simply go Queen back to a7 and the
material on the board is equal the
position is equal or always well for
both white and black select row Queen to
d2 Fischer doesn't go for this b3 rather
he immediately goes for the exchanges we
have Knight captures Knight captures
Queen captures and now rook captures on
b4 Queen to d7 and then out comes Queen
to e3 we have looked
rook to d8 attacking spassky's bishop on
d3 and now rook to b1 Spassky offers all
of the exchanges so Fischer accepts
royal Queen captors on d3 Queen captures
rook captures Queen rook captures Bishop
and now g5 making some room for a king
so Fisher doesn't get checkmated Rock
the BH check Spassky exchanges yet
another rock rock characters Rock
captures and now King g7 and as you can
see four pawns each on the Kings side
the rook each this is a completely drawn
endgame but a few more moves were played
f3 rugby - I will have h4 and now comes
h6 and H captures on g5 and here without
recapturing on g5 this is only moved 29
it was actually Fischer who offered a
draw and Spassky accepted the draw offer
so not not perhaps the greatest showing
with white pieces from Spassky but he
does have to bounce back and I figure
out how he wants to proceed in this
match and perhaps perhaps a more rest
will do him good
so now this was game 9 of the 1972 World
Chess Championship match between Robert
James Fischer and Boris recidivate
Spassky yeah
now as gaming on was played so out of
the seven games that were played three
games were drawn and four games were won
by Fischer so it seems like after that
one game that Spassky won it is
definitely all Fischer this entire match
but there are still more games to this
match and there are many more
interesting turn around so you know stay
tuned and we're just gonna have to keep
increasing our vast knowledge I would
like to thank Dani McCullough
Duras press normally come to Nikolas
roads and Chris Picard for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos ER
think all for watching and I'll see you
soon with continuing the Bobby Fischer
story but also I will check up on some
of your own suggestions I have an
excellent the rest of the Saturday and I
will see you soon